thinkI [ __ ] great see I'm pissed now
huh okay don't make noises oh well is
that more naked guys [ __ ] we can't go
back okay let's just key oh he's behind
me Stefan okay [ __ ] I hate doors where
he's phone oh hello hi always find
follow everywhere somehow oh we need to
go up here there what is that noise what
is that noise tell me no I I have to go
up wait maybe I can throw him up girls
the ball oh no come on come on I I'm not
going anywhere without you Stefano I
prepared I am come on I'm not pull super
no I can't no no no no I need a why Oh
maybe wait I haven't like that I'm like
I'm not good thing without Stefano [ __ ]
that not leaning him we're not leaving
in behind I'm a true [ __ ] soul here
I'm not going out anywhere without safar
oh he's a bro Anna brought help and now
I'm gonna happen cuz he's a bra
umbrellas help each other that's the bro
code bro code right here maybe I'm gonna
I need the person why who put a ledge
here come on oh I need and I'm tiny
wrong that's what she said whatever okay
I'm not leaving him behind
some other FN Stefano not going in my
tight freaking em anywhere without
refiner okay he's not gonna like this
idea but we have to do it let's force
the finite it's for a good cause
okay then we go here I think is this way
yeah
[ __ ] all this and my leg still hurts I'm
not joking
[ __ ] I'm not one who complaints when I'm
in damage like there we go
[ __ ] I'm a genius you saved me thank you
you're a true soldier ok let's go now
where's the fun I'm uh playing this mad
without sivanna that's just how it is
like if he disappears so I have to click
in a door or something nope not playing
anymore did you do this too far no no
blast
well did those fires go I'm going to die
alone in this all without them there's
no time I'm coming from if I said it's
my last and all the shelter Gregory
Gregory Wow it's Gregory don't fall down
a hole that's what she said that made
sense
ok too many that's what she said yolks
ok let's go this way Stefano
oh this is scary is it water is it won't
wait I'm gonna put you here Savannah
don't fall down or anything and it's I
have no tinderboxes well that's
fan-fucking-tastic let's go this way
oh no I have to cook it the war it's ok
pity I believe in you you must continue
without me I will find another way and
I'll see you on this other side you have
to continue do it do it oh just don't
look back oh wow
[ __ ] gonna miss him I kill all of
them
[ __ ] gonna miss the father so much
my [ __ ] leg I like I did like this I
like need my my table oh man that was
like the worst year ever
okay I have nothing I need to find sofa
No
and that's [ __ ] fast
huh huh is that the clock
shut up most obnoxious clock ever
can you use this
okay that'd save me some time I guess
what are you doing
this is really scary Savannah something
is blocking the door
[ __ ] aha
okay it's okay I'll find a way
[ __ ] this room is big that's what you
said I guess if you think about rooms
that's but you know whatever let's go up
here again cuz I don't really know
break the pottery can't move this I
thought I saw oh it's the door I'm not a
man I suppose so
sandir I am I needs the font
nope yeah nope let's go here
come on really position arrow
fan-fucking-tastic yes yes it's the
final are you doing this
that's a pain thing there why is there
painting there maybe you can use these
it's funny cuz I know all the puzzles oh
wow oh Jesus
tell me all your secrets thesis oh I got
a tinderbox that's it
that's it I did that for a tender box
Jesus I command you
actually I don't command you anything
sorry don't kill me let's just kidding
I'm gonna go here you can have this
don't kill me don't kill me okay I can
jump in I know I know you put the box
here and then you do like that and then
you do 360 I don't agree to do 360 words
to like I think song oh oh oh I solved
it I solved it I saw the puzzle now
who's in the closet
it's locked well that's great
what does the momento say what is mr.
memento saying the door inside
maintenance is locked
that's not good ah don't rock hey let's
go in the nope door friend I have to go
in the no door let's be careful because
I don't trust nope I mean I don't trust
nobody oh no no no no no no I know this
is a nope door just gonna find a key and
get the [ __ ] out of here okay we got lie
tonight Adam Adam um actually it was the
sanity poison [ __ ] okay night school
it's cool I understand okay who's like
it's this it's like the sexiest thing
ever
okay actually actually now that I think
about it I'm taking him with me mister
leg hello oh oh no no no no no no no oh
[ __ ] he's in there
I'm a leg I'm a leg oh oh what's going
on huh mister leg I can't talk with you
okay well it's cold I can fix it what is
this all about
bro hello I'm dying you'll need to save
me you don't need the same hey why are
you touching yourself bro
why are you touching your - stop it
rabbit slab bunny why are you touching
yourself why are you touching yourself
it's not funny I'm dying why are you
touching ok I'm going with written mr.
leg okay
let's go here
I'm gonna put some mister leg on the
couch
haha Oh whatsapp roofer okay I got the
key
I got through Mickey Oh mr. Lake mr. lag
you so nice I don't trust you
good job mr. Lake you did a really good
job there Thank You Perry thank you
I did a pretty good job there I'll take
oh I personally lost my honor I did it I
did it so follow can't do that
I'm mr. mate so file up I'm a leg I'm a
freakin leg okay shut up leg Yuri I'm
nauseous I'm sorry people I'm sorry
[ __ ] saw only I need the sanity
potion ah don't drop me I'm a leg I'm a
leg jeez jeez ah Malay okay 360 Guinea
360 leg jump have you ever seen that
anyone new sure before I also world
record 360 leg job okay actually this is
not the right way this is this is the
way
okay miss leg let's go here I'm a leg ha
ha ha oh you can drop me first I'm a leg
sir it's fine I'm used to this kind of
stuff dropping me like it ha okay let's
go down oh man this is bad news
down bad use bad juice really miss leg
ha ha ha ha leg is he here
mr. leg boys where is you really I love
it
do you remember me chordal I remember
you Scully
what are you doing here I don't know I
was just looking for potatoes you know I
like potatoes
I can't walk here really
so I saw Stephane earlier he was looking
for you really where is he
I don't know but you'll see him soon
enough I'm sure I had the same accent
well from the same place you know me as
a father all good times me hey a lot of
cool stories to tell you
huh okay since Melvin's mysteries fate
lab would you want to read it Scully
okay I already did last Thursday I held
responsible meeting their generator
supplies are running thin and I pray
that to err will be sir survive this
winter I mean probably it's the damn
lava machine all is only stuff it reacts
to really received a large barrel of the
oil then last same day Mervin Merman
disappeared I feel looking for him tough
know no one knows what happened to the
man and horrible moans Giles it was
Giles all right that I mean of that
what's going on in here the poor Kelly's
lack [ __ ]
okay Savannah I mean what did you call
me I am so disappointed I'm not going
with you anymore I'm sorry's going [ __ ]
it just flew off that's what she said
okay the number I'll sign the site isn't
working the pressure day was broken
perhaps I need Final replay German too
many that's what she's then I love how I
always like I'll have wait till out of
my own that's what she said yokes it
looks extremely hot that's what she said
okay we need this and then we need like
we need like Euler or whatever I sure
will find you somewhere else but I can't
bring schist
scollay because I keep calling us the
fauna Oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I need Scully I need [ __ ]
Scully oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] any to hide he's
here somewhere
what is that he's behind the wall
[ __ ]
hello okay
oh-oh-oh-oh were you still in here
we're in okay so now we got an oil
filled good but seriously what's up with
this place okay it's nothing you said on
the machine and I think we're good to go
probably not but whatever I hear him I
[ __ ] hear him
okay so where do I use it exactly here
oh [ __ ] so creepy can I pull this
[Music]
scully tell me what to do I really don't
know
I need another lever where can I find a
lever this is blood and sad things
everywhere
I hate him I hate him
wow he really must hate me
I didn't think it was here like oh that
I need to scare 316
oh man I'm such a genius main power oh
good Oh for a lie this place different
wow I'm really confused oh it's very
picked up the oil if there was a room
here - wow this place is huge
I didn't know
oh this is behind the wall it's sweet to
have a tinderbox that explains where he
was come on so I put it here
I need fun a lever oh man the [ __ ]
monster
I think this is where we start off
what's in here I'm putting it there so
we know where we came from oh this is
where we came from good
come on I'm so lost
while we're here good PT good job good
job good job good job get the jab with
any mean elevator what was that
[ __ ] I don't really want to go there
anyway sir
I need you to fix this [ __ ] onion
let's read the notes or something
no-nothing knows mementos the pressure
leverage booking that were outside a
certain isn't working I need to
reactivate the power I can't click this
can click this
Fitbit oil on it it will be like
No
maybe I need to play something there
like cook cook some food or something
maybe Scully needs to be cooked no look
man I'm sorry I am I just need to do it
it's inevitable see I use fancy words
sometimes you got a problem like my
fainting words
hmm
what's the sec cracking sound
it's so creepy this should be able to
use us levers on well it's just a broken
share I really don't know what tada
there's nothing here
okay let's follow the light this time
and then doing that the last diamond and
that are being lost
I come on it's like rocks everywhere
then I hit this up oh here we go there
we go very freakin go I have a pressure
lever now I have a pressure lever now I
have a pressure lever now fresh forever
now fresh lamb now try the saying that
really quick official ever now pressure
level I appreciate allow fish another
outfit mom Triceratops Reptar rapping as
a monk and deaf rock stars - ecstatic
wigs made of n wash